the board of Germany's largest bank has
reportedly agreed to merger talks with
the second largest the veldt AM Sonntag
newspaper says the board of donk will
discuss a fusion with its traditional
rival Commerce Bank the German
government has been urging the two banks
to merge after years of losses Deutsche
Bank has also forced a faced scrutiny in
the US over a money-laundering scandal
joining me to unpack this is Stephen
visi from our business department Steve
hi thanks for joining me what more do we
know about this Rebecca I think the main
thing is that there's finally a mandate
for these merger talks there's been a
lot of talk about this for months going
on now as Deutsche has suffered such
serious losses and as recently as Friday
there were sources from comomatz Bank
saying it's absolutely nonsense if
there's a mandate for talks and now we
know that there's been one for at least
a week back on deutsche side if these
reports are correct we know that they're
still at the very early stages there's
small groups and that this has a long
way to go before it is approved well
there's been a lot of talk about this
merger for some time the banks
themselves haven't seemed keen why now
well I think first of all I think it's
interesting that this finally was
confirmed that these reports are correct
on a weekend that might tell you
something about what they want to see
with the blow or what they expect from a
blow on Monday but really the answer is
that it's coming now because the economy
is softening the global economy is
softening German exports are going down
the German economy is softening and
their concerns that if Germany doesn't
have an effective Bank to support its
it's German companies during a weak spot
in the economy with both of these banks
suffering then they're going to struggle
there is a strong preference in the
German government to have a strong
German national lender Deutsche Bank is
obviously really the focus of this it is
the biggest bank here and it carries the
name of Germany on it and as you
mentioned there been a lot of scandals
surrounding it has really gone through
years of unprofitability and despite
recent efforts are really shored up that
have really gone a long way it's just
not happening fast enough and so this
really isn't unexpected well the German
government pretty came but there's still
a lot of resistance right there is a lot
of resistance I mean any merger is gonna
have to get through first of all German
regulators and we can assume that it
would
get through those if there is preference
in the government for it but it's gonna
have to also get through European
regulators we know that on the European
side the ECB has really preferred a
merger between Deutsche Bank and a
European Bank they want to see greater
consolidation across the EU and they
believe it has to happen across national
lines for the German government there
isn't such a strong preference for that
of course they want a German champion
this gets into a bigger question of the
German government and national
governments in the EU really wanting to
put their thumbs on the scale and saying
we need our own banks support our own
businesses and of course then you look
at the job losses that could come about
through this the business models of both
banks are very similar the overlap very
nicely which means there's gonna be a
lot of deadweight to get rid of
politically that's going to be very very
unpopular so a lot of questions going
forward and it's not necessarily
guaranteed right I'll just mention
finally a lot of people say that too bad
banks combined does not make one good
thing
all right well like Oh eyes watching
that merger taught those merger to talk
Steve Beardsley from DW business thank
you